[Music]
all right today's question comes from
anthony in minnesota
anthony writes i've been saving money
without my wife
knowing uh-oh i've been taking more out
of my paycheck to put into my retirement
account and i also have been taking 65
dollars a paycheck and putting it into
an
online investing platform for another
savings account
i know this isn't right but i feel as if
it is the only way to save
i want to more aggressively pay down
debt but my wife thinks
debt is normal i can't convince her to
be more frugal and i know we should pay
off debt with this money
but i'm afraid that once i do that we
will just get back into debt
i'm lying to my wife to attempt to
provide and it hurts
what should i do stop lying
all right that's why you got two
doctoral degrees right there
stop lying um
finding yourself in a challenge and
lying to get around that challenge takes
that challenge and sets it on fire
so the first thing you got to do is stop
lying
and so
i completely agree i mean and he's he
agrees yeah he knows he knows
he knows but so tell him what he should
do
man what he should do this is not a
tolerable situation no
and this is not a money situation this
is something that's deeper than this if
he thinks he's having to lie to protect
his wife
if he's having to go behind her back in
multiple different ways
um then they've got bigger challenges in
their marriage
and this this type of activity lets me
think that he thinks it's okay
or not okay but he's feels like he has
to lie in other areas and that she may
be hiding stuff and so at the end of the
day
everybody's got to sit down and probably
at this point have a mediator
have a whether it's a marriage counselor
or a pastor or a friend that they trust
and
him and his wife need to have a what i
would say a truth-telling session they
need to get somewhere where they can be
honest with one another
and do a clinical blood work on their
marriage
how are they doing are they doing okay
they're not doing okay they're not
um but they need to put all cards on the
table how are we doing
and then they've got to move into i
can't continue to
be a part of a relationship where you
don't care about our future i can't be
in a relationship with you or you're
lying to me and hiding money from me
and everybody's got to come together and
they're not even ready to build the
future together because the foundation
of this thing is so cracked
over the years when i've looked at been
in these situations
and someone sitting in my office not as
a
phd in counseling but as as just a guy
who's helping them with their money
i often find
that it's almost like i want to give
this guy
a syringe with red bull in it
because he
instead of being aggressive enough
in the relationship to cause a crisis
in the relationship have a fit
or you say have a duck fit right right
you know i mean just
flopping around on the floor create a
crisis be aggressive
enough to go dadgummit this is not okay
right and you don't have to be mean or
nasty but this idea that i'm the
passivity
that has caused him to lie
as opposed to being aggressive and just
stand up in her face
and say no no more no
right and if you don't think yes then
we're gonna go see a marriage counselor
because
no we're not living like this we're not
going to live broke to broke to broke
and in debt our whole lives
just because you want to whine no
or you just want to spend or whatever it
is right
you know he just will not face her down
and i i just want to run down to walmart
on all four and pick him up a backbone
i said dude install it well the
challenge with the backbone is because
he's hiding out of cowardice
rather than courage but you have to have
an or what what happens
somehow he romanticized his
cowardice as if he's trying to take care
of his family with deception
right romanticize oh i'm doing this for
the good of my family
because you're a wuss you gotta have
hard conversations
but you also have to have an or what
moment right so what if she says
if you choose to get a dead i'm out
this tells me anthony's just punting
that inevitable
situation that's going to blow up at
some point so have the coverage here's
the thing
she's not going to no she's not she
yearns for somebody
to look her in the eyes and go we're
going to do this and
we're going to win we're going to do it
today and we're going to win
right nobody has ever made her believe
that you can win
and maybe just maybe it's her husband's
job in this case
not maybe for sure you know i mean i'm
being sarcastic but i mean
dude step up man up
woman up woman my husband i have to hide
from him because he's a little boy
and he wants to spend all his money on a
lunch room and i
you know i have to give him money he's
not he's not your son
he's your husband look him in the eye
and tell him to man
up no more right you know so there is
something about this kind of deception
that has a passivity to it
versus being proactive and aggressive
to actually get to the problem in the
relationship because the relationship's
the problem
not the money that's exactly right just
it's just a it's a red
flashing light saying danger will
robinson this thing's going down
right yeah gosh we're gonna have to go
back and get lost in space clips
again because there's a whole generation
that does not know what the robot looks
like danger whale robin's
danger with those hands look at those
hands dangerous
that's right you know and then he would
he'd always get unplugged that's right
every lost in space episode right but to
everyone out there
when they are helping their marriage by
hiding
or lying or stealing or cheating
you're not you're being a wuss you're
not facing reality you're in an effort
because you didn't have the courage to
cause a problem
you're causing a bigger problem that's
right in the nerd world they call it
one down where i instead of causing a
scene
on top i'm just going to gently drag
this boat from underwater i'm going to
pull the whole thing down it's going to
take a long time
and it's the one down power move i can't
win up here i am not going to
head on up here so i'm just going to
gently be an anchor and pull this whole
thing down
slowly drowned us oh my gosh right
and that's what hiding and slipping
around the corners and
and got this account in that account man
you're gonna slowly drown i'd rather see
the thing go down in flames because you
went out swinging right yeah
yeah i put all the cards on the table i
brought a friend i brought a pastor i
bought a marriage counselor
this is what this is versus as for me
and my house
this is the way it's gone the way it's
gonna be you know and you do you know
the interesting thing is is that
people who are struggling with hope who
don't believe that it can that you can
win
when you declare with courage that we're
going to do what it takes to win
they are so thankful for that and it's
it's when your teenager doesn't believe
that they can make it
right and you declare with courage we're
going to do whatever it takes by god for
you to learn to do this that's right
leadership we're gonna we're gonna get
tutors uh we're gonna we're gonna work
until midnight i'm gonna stay up with
you we're gonna have calluses on our
hands and on our brain we're getting
this crap done that's right
and you're gonna win and you are not
going down in flames on my watch you're
going to turn the electronics off you're
going to stop
x and you're going to stop why right
it's not just affirmative you've got to
stop you've got to change your life too
right we're going to do the thing what
it takes for
us to win what has to be true we're
going to make a list of those things
we're going to turn off that turn on
that that's right and we're going
and that that kid who is depressed and
hopeless and looking down
and and rebellious and everything else
is just going to go thank god
somebody can't let cares me enough to
bust me in the mouth
metaphorically and cause this to happen
and that's man i've seen that in
leadership inside these walls in this
business
i've seen that in families i've seen it
everywhere else you have to have the
courage to cause a scene
which in my head is gonna turn the
lights on right yeah my friend my friend
seth jordan says cause a ruckus cause a
ruckus i was a ruckus no more
you know and do it in the marketplace go
make a ruckus in the marketplace
that's good stuff very good stuff stop
lying anthony
[Music]
yeah it right
calls a ruckus a lot of a lot of
education to say stop lying because
those are ruckus love it so that you
don't have to lie anymore
this is the dave ramsey show